Новини дня «heute» з Мітрієм Зіріним.
Добрий вечір.
З новинами спорту - Норберт Леман.
П'ятниця повільно добігає кінця.
Сьогодні було ухвалено чимало
важливих рішень. Саме про них ми й розповімо.
Рішення суду матиме далекосяжні наслідки:
Верховний суд США скасував
федеральне право на аборти,
тож тепер окремі штати зможуть
приймати більш жорсткі закони.
Як подолати глобальну кризу голоду?
Нестача продовольства особливо
відчутна для жителів Ємену.
Рішення мають знайти на міжнародній
конференції з продовольчої безпеки у Берліні.
Відпустка без стресу? Та де там!
На початку відпустки відпочивальникам
у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії доводиться годинами
стояти у чергах в аеропорту
через нестачу фахівців.
Розпочнімо з історичного рішення суду,
що матиме далекосяжні наслідки.
Верховний суд США скасував
федеральне право на аборти,
закріплене у Конституції 50 років тому.
Ухвалення цього рішення - великий успіх
для консерваторів та релігійних правих.
Для активістів, що виступають за
права жінок, та лібералів - день трауру.
На думку президента США
Байдена, це - жахлива помилка.
Штати можуть запровадити
значні обмеження щодо абортів.
Для суспільства це - чергове випробування.
Детальніше у сюжеті
Анни Файст із Вашингтона.
Тут зіткнулися два різні світи.
У ці хвилини у Вашингтоні
поблизу Верховного суду США
триває протистояння
прихильників та противників абортів.
Сьогодні вранці було ухвалено рішення
щодо скасування ліберального федерального
закону про аборти, прийнятого 50 років тому.
Аборт - процес, повний жорстокості,
який шкодить і жінкам, і дітям.
З 1973 року було вбито понад 1 млрд людей.
Настав час покласти цьому край.
Заборона абортів - лише перший крок.
Чимало людей тут думають інакше.
Конгрес має провести
розслідування щодо Верховного суду.
Забороняти аборти - нелегально. Конгрес
має виконувати свою роботу як слід.
Верховний суд, у якому переважну
більшість мають консерватори,
обґрунтовує скасування закону так:
«Конституція не надає права на аборт.
Повноваження з регулювання переривання
вагітності знову належить народу
та його обраним представникам».
І вони вже почали діяти.
Відсьогодні у 13 штатах набули
чинності так звані «тригерні закони».
Вони забороняють або значно
обмежують здійснення абортів.
Більшість з них не передбачають винятків,
як от аборт у разі зґвалтування чи інцесту.
У інших 13 штатах поки немає нового регулювання.
Втім, вони передбачатимуть
заборони та суворі обмеження.
У штатах Нью-Йорк та Каліфорнія
закріпили право на аборт.
Обґрунтування суду також містить низку
рекомендацій щодо переосмислення суджень
щодо засобів контрацепції,
одностатевих стосунків та шлюбів.
Демократи Палати представників США
б'ють на сполох:
«Немає сенсу казати «добрий ранок»,
адже він зовсім не добрий.
Сьогодні вранці Верховний суд США
позбавив американців права вибору
і поставив під загрозу їхнє здоров'я та безпеку.
Проте Конгрес й надалі буде робити усе
можливе для подолання цього екстремізму
та захищатиме народ Америки».
Але без абсолютної більшості демократи навряд
можуть щось вдіяти.
Тим часом поблизу Верховного суду
з`являється дедалі більше демонстрантів.
Вони розгнівані.
Бенні Деніел наразі перебуває
у Вашингтоні поблизу Верховного суду США.
Як демонстранти відреагували,
дізнавшись рішення суду?
Реакції дуже неоднозначні.
Наразі ми стоїмо перед будівлею суду.
Сюди сходяться тисячі людей.
Серед них, з одного боку,
противники абортів, які щиро радіють рішенню суду.
З іншого боку, переважна більшість людей тут
виступають за легальність абортів.
Хоча рішення суду не було несподіваним,
це не вкладається в голові.
Декілька хвилин тому з цієї
нагоди виступав президент США.
Він зазначив, що це похмурий
день для Верховного суду
та сумний день для усієї країни.
Він зробить усе можливе
для протидії цьому рішенню.
Що це рішення означає для США?
Насамперед це означає, що
процес соціального зцілення,
про який, певно, мріяв
Джо Байден, віддаляється у часі.
Це рішення скасовує інше рішення Верховного суду,
ухвалене майже 50 років тому в 1973 році.
І рішення 1973 року, і рішення,
ухвалене сьогодні, справді історичні.
Тільки по-різному.
Зараз консервативна меншість перемогла
проти волі переважної більшості американців.
Це, безумовно, призведе до ще
більшої соціальної поляризації.
Ось цей протест - лише початок.
Впродовж наступних декількох місяців в Америці,
безперечно, буде неспокійно через це рішення.
Зокрема, з огляду на проміжні
вибори, що відбудуться у листопаді.
Дякую.
Поговорімо про аборти у Німеччині.
Бундестаг скасував заборону на
розміщення інформації про аборти
закріплену у параграфі 219а.
У минулому через цю заборону
було засуджено багатьох лікарів.
Однак сьогодні, попри те,
що Союз CDU/CSU та AfD
проголосували проти, Бундестаг скасував цю норму.
Це означає, що жінки із небажаною вагітністю
зможуть швидше та легше
отримати необхідну інформацію.
Детальніше про це розповість Сара Таке.
Ця жінка має судимість,
адже як лікарка загальної практики
розміщувала на своєму веб-сайті
інформацію про те, що робить аборти.
Так Крістіна Генель порушила параграф 219а
Кримінального кодексу, який сьогодні скасували.
Адже у ньому, зокрема, зазначено:
«Будь-яку особу, що публічно
пропонує послуги зі здійснення
чи сприяння перериванню вагітності, буде покарано».
Те, що ми забороняємо
висококваліфікованим лікарям,
які здійснюють такі втручання,
надавати необхідну інформацію пацієнткам,
загрожуючи кримінальним покаранням, -
абсурд. Це - несправедливо
та не відповідає викликам сучасності.
Проти скасування проголосували AfD і Союз CDU/CSU.
З повним скасуванням параграфу 219а
Кримінального кодексу
ми уможливлюємо розміщення проактивної
реклами в інтернеті та, ймовірно, у журналах.
Тобто ми таким чином натякаємо,
що йдеться про нормальну медичну допомогу.
Багато хто погоджується з цим,
зокрема католицька церква.
Зрозуміло, що дебати триватимуть й надалі.
Однак сьогодні опівдні запеклу суперечку
вдалося вирішити політичним шляхом.
Боролася і сьогодні перемогла також Крістіна Генель.
Я ще не можу цього цілком усвідомити.
Скасування цієї заборони означає також, що
пацієнтки нарешті зможуть отримати
авторитетну та точну інформацію.
Вони вже давно мають на це право.
Для Крістіни Генель це також
означає, що незабаром вона
більше не матиме судимості.
Тому що новий закон передбачає
скасування вироку за параграфом 219а.
Поговорімо про Україну.
Понад місяць тривали запеклі
бої за місто Сєвєродонецьк.
Однак зараз українські військові отримали наказ
залишити місто, розташоване на сході країни.
В інтерв'ю для телебачення очільник
Луганської обладміністрації
зазначив, що немає сенсу
залишатися на розбитих позиціях.
Таким чином українські військові
контролюють лише одне місто
у Луганській області - сусіднє місто Лисичанськ.
Впродовж багатьох тижнів
це місто також перебуває
під масованими обстрілами та
може опинитися в оточенні росіян.
Бої тривають не лише на Сході України.
Наша репортерка Катрін Айґендорф
разом зі своєю командою
побувала на фронті на
півдні країни, у селі Широке.
Ми перебуваємо у селі Широке,
на лінії фронту у Херсонській області.
Російські військові всього
за декілька кілометрів звідси.
Андрій показує мені позицію на невеличкому
клапті лісу між полями, яку українські
військові утримують вже три місяці.
Триває боротьба із противником,
що має велику перевагу у техніці.
Наразі бійці покладаються на сучасну
зброю, що вже прибула в Україну.
Ситуація змінюється кардинально,
коли надходить нова зброя.
Одразу ж змінюється характер війни.
Андрій показує нам відео
останнього використання
єдиної артилерійської установки, яку вони
мають у своєму розпорядженні.
Техніка, яку солдати використовують
тут, на фронті, дуже стара.
Частково ще з радянських запасів.
Ось ця установка, наприклад,
виготовлена ще у 1984 році.
Українські військові кажуть,
що не можуть воювати
із росіянами, використовуючи застарілу техніку.
Ось чому для них так важливо, щоб Захід
постачав сюди зброю.
На південний фронт прибули
реактивні протитанкові гранатомети -
високоточна зброя з США та Великобританії.
Військові сподіваються, що
завдяки ним отримають перевагу.
Тому що у росіян хоч і більше зброї,
але вона значно старіша.
У ворога проблеми з точністю.
Вони просто рівняють усе із землею,
як у Луганській та Донецькій областях,
де наразі тривають головні бої.
Вони вбивають мирних жителів,
військових - їм байдуже.
У Херсонській області на південному фронті
військові сподіваються, що
завдяки цій зброї
хід війни зміниться на їхню користь.
Війна в Україні чітко показала, що Москва
використовує голод як зброю.
Про це заявила
міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини Бербок.
Оскільки Росія блокує експорт зерна з України,
продовольства бракує майже 400 млн людей.
Особливо в Африці та на Близькому Сході.
На всесвітній продовольчій
конференції у Берліні країна-господарка
Німеччина разом з іншими країнами
та організаціями намагалася знайти рішення.
Одне із них полягає в експорті
більшої кількості зерна залізницею
або альтернативними морськими шляхами.
Також Бербок закликала
посилити фінансову допомогу.
Для цього необхідно понад 44 млрд євро.
Тож через війну в Україні
погіршилося становище
й без того дуже бідних країн, що
постраждали від воєн та стихійних лих.
Наприклад, у Ємені на Близькому Сході.
За даними ООН, там мільйонам
людей загрожує голод.
Впродовж багатьох років у Ємені
триває громадянська війна.
Про потребу в продовольстві у
місті Сані, столиці Ємену,
розповість наша кореспондентка
Голіне Атай.
Сана - столиця повстанців хуситів.
Постріли в країні не лунали вже два місяці,
завдяки важким переговорам
та крихкому перемир'ю.
Але позитивні наслідки миру
будуть знищені іншою війною -
війною в Україні.
Високі ціни стали ще вищими.
Пшениця стає дефіцитним товаром,
від цього страждає найбідніше населення.
Ми отримували пшеницю та багато всього іншого
з Росії та України.
А тепер мішок пшениці коштує вдвічі дорожче.
Це лікарня Аль-Сабейн для людей, які через брак
їжі мають проблеми зі здоров'ям.
Щоб зрозуміти повний масштаб трагедії
в Ємені,
потрібно відвідати лікарню.
Ці діти так довго голодували, що їхнє тіло,
не в змозі приймати їжу,
навіть якщо вони її отримуватимуть.
Половина дітей в країні до п'яти років,
2,2 мільйона, страждають через гостре недоїдання.
За словами медбрата,
випадки пов'язані з недоїданням
за останні кілька місяців зросли майже вдвічі.
Дитячий фонд ООН підтримував тут таких дітей.
Але підтримка припинилася,
і тепер ми нічого не отримуємо.
Тепер лікування відбувається коштом пацієнта.
Відсутність пожертв для Ємену
також впливає і на дворічного Заїда.
Він завжди хворий, йому просто не стає краще.
Нам потрібна допомога спонсорів,
і я сподіваюсь, що мені дадуть ліки для нього.
У нас нічого немає.
Благодійні організації попереджають:
у другій половині року ситуація стане ще важчою,
і приблизно 19 млн людей в Ємені
страждатимуть від голоду.
У Брюсселі завершився саміт ЄС.
Темами останніх днів стали
високі ціни на енергоносії та дефіцит газу.
Канцлер Шольц сказав,
що ЄС на правильному шляху
до кращої координації енергетичної політики.
Зроблено все можливе для імпорту енергії
з інших країн, окрім Росії.
Щодо Афганістану:
число загиблих після сильного землетрусу
збільшилася щонайменше до 1100 жертв.
Сьогодні знову були поштовхи на сході країни.
Вважають, що під завалами
знаходиться ще багато жертв.
За даними ООН, деякі віддалені села
досі не змогли отримати допомогу.
Тести на коронавірус для громадян незабаром
перестануть бути безкоштовними.
За словами міністра охорони здоров'я Лаутербаха,
ситуація з бюджетом досить напружена,
аби це забезпечити.
Для більшості людей
незабаром вартість тесту становитиме 3 євро.
Відповідно до нового розпорядження від 30 червня,
тест залишатиметься безкоштовним
для груп ризику серед яких:
діти до п'яти років,
жінки з раннім строком вагітності,
а також відвідувачі клінік та будинків для
літніх людей.
Вже кілька місяців від партії «Лівих»
не було нічого чути.
У партії був період затишшя
після поразок на виборах, кадрових суперечок
і звинувачень у сексизмі.
На федеральній партійній конференції
лідерка партії Вісслер намагалася переконати
своїх однодумців почати все спочатку.
Прямо з Ерфурта - Андреа Маурер.
Це момент, коли партії «Лівих», здається, вдалося
ненадовго забути
про останні кілька місяців поразок на виборах,
боротьби за владу та занепаду.
Овації навстоячки для Джанін Вісслер.
Більше пів години виснажена лідерка виступала
зі зверненням до своєї виснаженої партії.
Настрої були бойовими:
Давайте будемо більше пробачати один одному,
перестанемо звинувачувати один одного
в соціальних мережах
і публічно демонструвати помилки.
Давайте дискутуватимемо всередині партії,
але разом боротимемось проти зовнішніх опонентів
та будемо поруч із тими, хто сподівається на нас.
Партія «Лівих» в Ерфурті хоче оновити
свою програму та кадри.
Занадто багато є суперечливим,
занадто багато незрозумілим:
наприклад, відносини з Росією.
Завтра відбудеться голосування
щодо курсу зовнішньої політики.
Сьогодні прем’єр-міністр Тюрингії
звернувся до прихильників Путіна,
які є у складі його партії:
«Майте на увазі, що Путін не належить до лівих.
І не є прихильником лівих.
Він є самодержавцем і тим,
хто почав імперіалістичну війну.»
З нетерпінням очікують загальні дебати
щодо руху «Linke-Metoo»,
які мають відбутися сьогодні.
Партія створила слідчу комісію
після звинувачень
у сексизмі та сексуальних домаганнях.
Для молодіжної асоціації,
яка виступає від імені багатьох постраждалих,
цього недостатньо:
«Загалом це не є темою обговорення,
і я також маю відчуття,
що це не повинно бути темою обговорення тут,
на партійній конференції.
Повинно бути вольове рішення розібратися
з цим питанням зараз,
почати діяти, щоб це не продовжувалося.»
Завтра також будуть обирати
нове керівництво партії.
Джанін Вісслер знову балотується.
Після двох виснажливих карантинних років,
як ніколи хочеться насолоджуватися
літнім сонцем і купанням.
Однак довгоочікувана відпустка затьмарюється
нестачею персоналу в авіакомпаніях
та співробітників аеропорту.
Тисячі пустих робочих місць,
тисячі скасованих рейсів.
Що це означає для найбільшої землі
в Німеччині, Північного Рейну-Вестфалії,
де саме сьогодні розпочнуться літні канікули,
розкаже Ян Гофер з репортажем.
Перший напій перед зльотом -
саме так авіакомпанії аеропорту Дюссельдорфа
хочуть зменшити стрес своїх пасажирів.
Годинами стояти в черзі, щоб здати валізи в багаж.
Для декого це триває так довго,
що в результаті літак злітає без них.
Тут стільки народу, що ми не можемо пройти,
ми дві години стояли в черзі й пропустили рейс.
У нас новий рейс.
Завтра вранці ми спробуємо ще раз.
Раніше потрібно було бути в аеропорту
за дві години до вильоту,
тепер всі процедури займають
набагато більше часу.
Багато хто приходить на 4-5 годин раніше.
Ми прибули сюди сьогодні вранці о 7:30,
наш літак вилітає одразу після 12:00.
Ми щойно чекала дві години,
щоб здати наші валізи до багажу.
Я часто літаю, але ніколи не бачила аеропорт
таким переповненим.
Якщо черга на реєстрацію занадто довга,
або рейс скасували,
ви маєте право на компенсацію і новий рейс.
Однак зараз багато людей пропускають рейси
через довгі черги перед зоною контролю.
Якщо через контроль безпеки ви пропустили рейс,
тоді вам доведеться мати справу з державою,
оскільки служба безпеки
належить до державних органів.
Авіакомпанії до них не мають жодного відношення,
тому відшкодування потрібно вимагати від держави.
Принаймні, все це досить складно для мандрівників.
Подорож у відпустку літаком у багатьох аеропортах
стане можливою лише для людей
з міцними нервами.
Чи є загроза туристичного хаосу?
Ми обговоримо у «ZDFheute live» о 19:30.
Чому багато вакансій залишаються відкритими,
ви можете дізнатися на наших каналах у соціальних
мережах і у додатку «ZDFheute».
Там ви знайдете детальнішу інформацію про права,
які має пасажир у разі скасування його рейсу.
А тепер про спорт: і знову сьогодні йтиме мова
про мультиспортивний захід у Берліні, про фінал.
Чемпіонати Німеччини з 14 видів спорту -
190 титулів вручать у столиці до неділі.
Сьогодні колишній чемпіон світу у штовхані ядра
Давид Шторл здобув один із них,
прямо посеред Берліну
перед Бранденбурзькими воротами.
Шторл здобув свій десятий титул чемпіона
з найкращим результатом сезону - 20,32м.
Однак це знову значно нижче норми
для Чемпіонату світу в США в липні.
Саймон Байєр виборов друге місце, випередивши
чинного чемпіона Денніса Лукаса,
результат обох не був більше ніж 20 м.
Діючий чемпіон Лукас Даузер переміг у фіналі
з гімнастики,
випередивши Філіпа Гердера та Гленна Требінга.
Після слабкого старту Даузер,
срібний призер Олімпійських ігор на паралельних брусах,
захищає свій титул
завдяки сильному виступу.
На річці Шпрее байдарочники
Юле Хааке та Якоб Шопф
(на фото внизу) виграли спринт на 160 метрів.
У фіналі Шопф,
який завоював олімпійське срібло в Токіо,
та його партнерка з Люнена
з мінімальним відривом
перемогли дует Пауліни Пашек та Макса Лемке.
Спортивна гімнастка Дар'я Варфоломєєва
вперше стала чемпіонкою Німеччини
з багатоборств.
15-річна спортсменка здобула перемогу над
діючою чемпіонкою Маргаритою Колосовою.
Варфоломєєва виграла для Німеччини
першу за 42 роки медаль
на чемпіонаті Європи,
що відбувся в Ізраїлі у вихідні.
Успішна генеральна репетиція
жіночої збірної Німеччини
перед чемпіонатом Європи в Англії,
який відбудеться через два тижні:
Команда DFB перемогла
в товариському матчі в Ерфурті
проти Швейцарії з рахунком 7-0.
Клара Бюль забила три голи,
у тому числі цей майстерний удар,
забезпечивши Німеччині
перемогу над швейцарцями.
На чемпіонаті світу з плавання у Будапешті
Флоріан Веллброк
показав приклад, вигравши попередній заплив
на своїй дистанції.
Діючий чемпіон був найшвидшим
на дистанції 1500 метрів.
Другим приплив українець Михайло Романчук,
який разом із Веллброком тренувався у Магдебурзі
від початку війни в Україні.
Третім приплив американець Боббі Фінк.
Завтра ввечері буде заплив на 1500 метрів,
який вирішить все.
На жаль, грози продовжуватимуться,
докладніше розповість Кріста Орбен.
Не пропустіть інтерв'ю з міністром сільського
господарства Оздеміром у виписку «heute journal»
о 22:00 з Марієттою Сломкою.
Завтра у студії вас вітатиме Барбара Гальвеґ.
Команда «heute 19 Uhr» дякує вам
та бажає гарних вихідних.
Доброго вечора, антициклон над країнами Балтії
до сьогоднішнього дня приносив на
північному сході багато сонця і тепла.
Але це змінилося, через рух циклону,
який рухає хмари на північний схід.
Сьогодні вночі грози також рухатимуться на схід.
Будьте обережними у першій половині ночі:
в регіоні між Альпами та середньою Саксонією
найбільша небезпека сильних дощів.
Місцями можливі затоплення підвалів та паводки.
Очікується також град і пориви вітру.
У другій половині ночі негода зачепить
схід Баварії та південь Саксонії.
На півночі також подекуди пройдуть грози та зливи,
загальна грозова активність
з просуванням на захід значно зменшується.
Температура вночі буде помірною,
завтра вранці на річках Одер та Нейсе
температура становитиме від 10° до 18°.
Завтра очікуємо літні температури,
між 23° і 30° в Альтмарк,
так само як і на узбережжі сьогодні.
Повітря з дощами та грозами
все ще нависає над сходом.
Іноді тут ще йтимуть сильні дощі.
В інших регіонах негода вщухне, особливо на
південному заході, там буде багато сонця.
З неділі на сході буде справді спекотно,
а із заходу прийдуть нові грози,
які будуть особливо сильними у понеділок.
До зустрічі.